let's move to the republican national
convention which had its second night
last night
and tried out a softer more positive
message at least compared to night one
and it was capped off by
first lady melania trump in a rare
campaign speech
from the white house rose garden she did
not mention democratic
nominee joe biden instead mr trump
offered sympathy
to victims of the ongoing coronavirus
pandemic that was notable
the convention also featured repeated
examples of trump administration
officials mixing government
and politics is at the white house for
us following all of this
we should good morning to you why is it
significant that officials mixed
government business and politics
good morning tony and good morning to
everybody the white house was used as a
prominent backdrop and multiple
official duties were conducted at a
campaign event which is
possibly a violation of the hatch act
which prohibits government employees
from participating in some political
activities while on the job
but it is worth noting that president
trump has the final say
to determine if someone violated the
hatch act and he has made clear that
positive
optics outweigh any potential ethics
violations
the second night of the republican
national convention put the power of the
presidency
on display at a political event in an
unprecedented way
as i grant john i'm not sure you know
this
a full pardon beginning with president
trump's pardoning of john ponder
a convicted bank robber who has since
founded a program helping former inmates
reenter society
raise your right hand the president also
oversaw a naturalization ceremony at the
white house
even though his administration has taken
controversial actions to limit
legal immigration to the u.s we welcome
five
absolutely incredible new members into
our great
american family mike pompeo violated his
own department's policy
banning diplomats from engaging in
political activity
the state department insisted pompeo
spoke in his personal capacity
but he praised mr trump's foreign policy
accomplishments while on an official
trip
in jerusalem this president has led bold
initiatives in nearly every corner of
the world
as on the first night president trump's
children made a passionate plea
to support their father this is a fight
for freedom versus oppression to every
proud american who bleeds
red white and blue my father will
continue
to fight for you but for the most part
speakers
avoided the continued impact of the
coronavirus pandemic
still gripping the nation white house
economic adviser larry kudlow
even referred to the pandemic in the
past tense
then came a once in 100 year pandemic
but presidential leadership came swiftly
and effectively
with an extraordinary rescue for health
and safety to successfully fight the
covet virus
the only significant acknowledgement of
the coronavirus came from an
empathetic melania trump my prayers are
with those
who are ill or suffering
i know many people are anxious
and some feel helpless i want you to
know
you're not alone speaking before the
president
and a live audience in the rose garden
the first lady also made a point to
acknowledge the protests for racial
justice take a moment
pause and look at things from all
perspectives
i urge people to come together in a
civil manner
so we can work and live up to our
standard
american ideals
before that event the white house said
that everyone in the audience would
receive a coven 19 test but this morning
the campaign
is not confirming that only saying they
consulted with an advisor
and took necessary precautions but
almost
everybody who attended that event in the
rose garden did not wear
a mask as you can see in this video
right here tonight vice president mike
pence will accept his re-nomination both
he
and his wife are expected to speak on
night three
of the convention tony
all right weeja thank you very much
we'll be watching